Welcome back, master and princess!
I don't know if the game is...
It's like a square.
Is it supposed to...
Should I crop it?
I don't...
I don't know.
I can't figure it out.
I don't know if it will get bigger when we play or not.
I can't tell.
I think it's supposed to be like that.
It's supposed to be like that in the menu.
It'll be widescreen once we...
Okay, okay, okay.
You can totally tell that I...
tested this out like a...
like a professional would, right?
I'm a professional.
Anyway, welcome guys to The Sims 2.
I hope you are having a good weekend.
I...
got my dinner.
So I'm gonna...
Sorry.
I went and got it kind of last minute.
So I have...
a salad.
Salad.
I'm really enjoying the Peace Walker streams.
Thank you, George!
I have a salad.
Today.
I'm gonna try eating it at this very moment.
Fix the audio?
What's wrong with the audio?
What are you talking about?
It's okay?
I think maybe, buddy, you got a second tab open.
Are you sure it's...
It's me?
What's going on?
Tomato.
I'm getting One Guide.
I don't know.
Classic One Guide.
Stop the voices in my head.
I can't do anything about that for you.
Because I'm supposed to deal with my in-head voices too?
Huh?
Started Astro Ball yesterday.
I hope you like it!
It's your birthday?
Happy birthday, SoulSmug!
Let me sing a happy birthday.
I thought the game I was playing had horrible echo music earlier, but I had two instances of it open.
That happens to me sometimes too.
I'll be like, what's wrong with this person's stream?
And it's because I'm obsessed with them and I just...
I couldn't wait.
I had to have every tab be them and then they all started at the...
Like, they start at like the same time, but like...
Slightly different, right?
So it's like, one started before the other.
And so it's just like a little...
Wait,
let me sing you a happy birthday first.
Let me sing you a happy birthday first, SoulSmug.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear SoulSmug!
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much for the five gifts.
Thank you!
And Vijay!
Thank you for the five gifts.
I hope you're okay.
Someone sent me a video, not too long ago.
Of the Chocolate Rain guy.
And he's streaming, but there's like something...
It's like causing his audio to loop.
And then by the end... He's playing like Team Fortress or something.
Thank you for the five gifts.
And Drago, thank you for the 20 gifts.
Can't stay long tonight, thanks for streaming though.
Thank you for being here!
The video's a classic?
I've never seen it before.
So funny.
Oh my gosh.
Gotta look it up.
What's that guy's name?
Chocolate Rain Man.
I meant Y2.
Why The Sims 2?
So, okay.
Let me get into it too.
Because some people are like, wow Minto, you tried playing The Sims before.
And it was a disaster.
And you're trying again?
You're really giving them another chance?
You're giving... It's EA, right?
You're giving them a second chance?
Well apparently...
They...
Which fixes it.
But also...
I was... I don't know.
I think it's because if I tried playing The Sims 1 again.
Because I had such a stinky time with it.
I was just like...
Maybe we'll just switch it up a little bit.
So...
And it seems to be working.
Because Nimi has been playing The Sims 2.
And she's able to play it.
So I was like...
Well...
Maybe it's okay.
Maybe.
Maybe I just have bad luck.
Who knows.
I mean, that's true.
I'm not one of God's favorite children.
That's why I was kicked out of heaven.
Not kicked out.
I left.
But you know...
Wait, she did break it?
But like...
How recent?
How recent is that?
Like two months ago?
Oh, that is before the patch then.
That's before the patch.
The patch is kind of recent.
Pretty sure.
Anyway.
Sorry, I'm eating my salad.
I'm eating my salad.
And then we're going to start.
That's a pretty big salad.
Where should we...
Where should we go?
Should we become normal?
And just live in Pleasant View?
I did not know...
That there's like lore and stuff in Strangetown.
Recently, I've been on like Sims TikTok.
And I'm learning about like...
The mothership.
And all this stuff that makes the Sims in the town become zombies.
Wait, the cafe is not in heaven?
No.
It's in... No.
It never has been.
Wondering Taco!
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you!
There's Sims lore?
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, Bella Goth lore goes crazy!
So crazy.
I recommend you guys doing like a deep dive on it.
Because it's actually really fascinating.
Because, oh my gosh, it gives me like...
It gives me like...
Okay, this is going to sound really stupid though.
But you know how like in Five Nights at Freddy's...
They don't like explain the lore to you in your face?
Like you kind of have to read it through like...
It's like...
You read it through like the newspaper clippings on the wall.
And things like that.
And it's like that.
Where you like kind of read things.
Because of how like they're like...
Oh, who is in this person's graveyard?
Or like what does their bio say?
And things like that.
Like it's very...
Passive storytelling.
Yes!
Very in between the lines.
So it's actually really cool.
I like that.
It's like my favorite kind of storytelling.
Dark Souls?
Dark Souls is like that too?
No way.
She's my Sim's wife.
I love the Bella Goth lore.
Interesting.
I thought you liked Exposition a la Metal Gear Solid.
I like when things are...
Well, okay.
Maybe...
Let me back up.
It is my favorite type of storytelling in horror.
So like because this is kind of like...
It's with Bella Goth and stuff.
It's a little like creepy.
It's my favorite kind of like...
You know, and then FNAF is also a horror game.
So it's like...
My favorite kind of storytelling in like a...
Creepy...
Way.
You know?
We're just like...
Spooky.
I love subtle horror.
I don't know.
Okay, let's go to Strangetown.
Strangetown.
Gosh, this whole interface is so nostalgic.
I played the most out of The Sims 2.
So...
Fushigi.
It has environmental storytelling.
The cassettes.
Yeah.
Maybe not quite the same.
But you could play the whole game and never...
Well...
You have to listen to some of them.
But you could play the whole game and...
Not listen to all of them.
I'm amazing.
Thanks, Young Riles.
Thanks for 11 months.
Creating hobbies.
We're creating magic!
No way.
This is too...
This is too cool.
We're creating...
Nothing.
Alien!
Oh my gosh.
So nostalgic.
I
love The Sims 2!
Apartment life.
Too real.
Mansion and garden stuff.
I think the alien invasion might spell ruin for the town.
You guys!
I wasn't making it up.
It's real.
Real lore.
Oh my gosh.
I love that show.
I used to watch that show everyday with my grandma.
With the guy who was on Star Trek.
He hosted it.
Beyond Belief, Fact or Fiction.
And now it's like a meme.
It's so funny.
I used to love that show.
We made it up.
Jonathan Frakes!
Yes!
My grandma loved that show so much.
In Strangetown, nothing is what it seems.
What are the different pictures?
Oh!
In search of truth and mystery.
The Three Curious Brothers.
Pascal, Vitkund, and Lazlo got more than they were...
I was expecting.
They really become...
I thought...
They were maybe...
They...
End prank?
Okay.
Can they cope with their new roles as cosmic parents?
After...
Oh my god.
Alien.
After a fruitful career, Pollination Technician 9 has retired to his favorite planet.
But can his son Johnny make friends and fit in?
Or is this family just too strange for Strangetown?
What experiments are the highly secretive and less than neighborly Loki and Cersei?
Performing on poor Nervous Subject.
Is that his name, Nervous Subject?
Wow.
Would you guys like it if I called you that?
Hey there, Nervous Subject.
Are you ready for today's experiment?
Today we're...
Dunking your feet in hot water.
Yeah.
Will this secrecy affect Cersei's career ambitions?
What does she want to do?
She wants to...
She wants to get promoted.
Tank has always lived under the hard thumb of his father, General Buzz Grunt.
In this domesticated boot camp, can Tank prove his worth to his demanding dad?
There are so many people here.
Nervous Wisps, rise up!
Who is buried in Olive Specter's garden?
Will the mysterious aging outcast leave her fortune to her niece Ophelia?
Or as rumored, to an unnamed heir.
She's in love with a zombie.
I think we're going to have our own family today.
How do I zoom out?
There we go.
Wow, strange town.
Is this some prime real estate right here or what?
Wait, whose house is this?
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh, this is the...
This is the weirdo Beaker family.
I think we should...
build our own family.
And meet all these crazy fellas.
What do you guys think?
I think we should have a Curious.
The Curious family.
Oh, it's the guys!
Where's your baby?
Wait, can I go see them real quick?
I just want to look.
Which one's pregnant, is what I'm wondering.
My bets are on Lazlo.
I don't know who...
Oh, oh.
Sims have aspirations.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me get a little bit smaller for this, I think.
Let's move like here.
That should be good.
You, you're pregnant?
Unlock new rewards.
I think I'll be able to remember pretty easily...
how to do this.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, thank goodness he doesn't want to woohoo.
I feel like all the...
Alien!
Wait, is none of them pregnant?
Um, no.
It happened in front of me!
What?
Which one?
Oh, it wasn't Lazlo.
It was...
What the hell is this?
What is this show?
It's a horror!
How did he...
How did he get pregnant?
Wait, what's the controls here?
Oh gosh, it doesn't tell me.
You guys, shut up.
You're watching the TV.
Okay.
What is happening?
But he wants to meet aliens.
That's his big aspiration.
It's so loud.
Turn it down!
Turn it off.
You don't need to watch this anymore.
Well...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, what does Pascal want?
He wants to...
No, turn it off!
Someone gets pregnant sounds about right.
Look, they have their little crib ready and everything.
Go relax, pregnant man.
You're okay.
Go relax.
Oh, you need to pee.
Oh, that's not a...
That's not...
I gotta get used to...
They didn't flush?
I like how their beds are...
Oh, there's technically two different rooms.
I was gonna say their beds are touching.
I don't think this is his room, maybe.
Do we say congratulations?
I wanna see the baby.
I want to see the baby.
Oh, he flushed.
Good job.
Okay, he also has to pee.
Everybody go to the bathroom.
Oh, he has to...
He has to pee the most.
Guys...
How do we do the cheats?
How do we do the cheats, guys?
Is he just sniffing the pizza?
Hey, that's so rude!
Don't watch him pee.
No, no.
Go pee.
He's unhappy because he's not peeing.
Eat the pizza.
How long do you think it will take for him to...
Okay, I'm gonna fast forward.
And we're just gonna wait for the baby to be born.
We'll let them do their own thing.
We'll let them have free will.
And the baby will be born.
And then...
We can see the little alien baby.
Do you think it will have his eyes or...
Oh, it's on the floor!
It's so...
What's happening?
Something is supposed to be happening.
Wait, what's going on?
It's broken?
What's going on?
What's happening?
There's no baby!
It's cut to nothing!
The
bouncing baby needs a name.
Minto.
Look, it looks just like me actually.
Oh, nevermind.
I think I lied.
Anyway...Oh, who the hell are you?
Oh my gosh, why are you in your nervous subject?
When did you get here?
He came to yippy at the baby and then leaves.
What are you doing in our house?
What are you doing here?
Where are you going?
He's going upstairs again.
No, he's going downstairs.
Why didn't you just exit through the front door?
Is there a front door?
Yes!
He came over just to go woohoo at the baby.
And now he's going home.
Bye!
He needed to get his steps in.
Where did he come from?
Why was he here?
I know he wants to have a talk with him, but...
We're going to leave now.
Thank you very much every...oh not quit.
Go back to the neighborhood.
Yes, that was exciting.
Now we just witnessed a birth.
It hasn't even been a half hour.
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you!
Now everybody...
It's time for the grand creation.
We can have a family of just pets.
I like this.
Wait.
Critter.
In a world full of conflict, who knew that these two would fall so deeply in puppy love?
Despite being homeless, Danny and Sarah have stuck together throughout the years.
But Sarah wants a better life for their future little ones.
So they're looking for a good home to settle down.
My goodness.
And we also have...oh wait, the singles.
OK, but we're making a new family.
Those dogs have 200 simoleons.
What's our family name?
I'm going to make the Cheesy family.
And that's their motto.
It ain't easy being a Cheesy.
You know?
Because this guy is Chucky Cheesy.
He is...what is this?
A cat.
Wow, Chucky Cheesy!
Wait!
I could actually make...
Wait, can I actually make Butaro?
Wait, can I customize him?
OK, hold on.
No, he's like...OK, so Butaro is like...
Light brown...
Wait, I want to add some extra stuff.
Oh, like this, like this.
Oh, it's backwards.
Wait.
OK, that's brown.
And then...
No!
Oh, so cute.
No, it's got to be...it's opposite for my cat.
My cat is totally brown except little patches.
Add a new layer.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, I see how it works now.
I didn't have ever any of like the mods and things, so...
This is all new for me, you guys.
Wait, what?
What?
Oh my God, he's starting to look more like my cat.
I'm Chucky Cheesy.
Chucky Cheesy.
How do I change it though?
White back...
My cat is really brown.
He used to be not so brown.
Now he's turned brown.
I can even set the opacity.
This is crazy.
Choose a coat pattern.
Like that.
Oh, it's so cute.
But brown.
OK.
And this is like a light brown.
No, this is dark brown.
It's his face.
Brown face.
Brown.
Everywhere brown.
Oh my gosh, there's so much customization.
What the heck?
No, this is brown.
This is so crazy.
Why is it so detailed?
That's a fox?
No, that's my cat.
I changed his eye color.
Brown.
No, it's still dark.
He doesn't have any booties.
This looks kind of like my cat.
It actually looks nothing like my cat.
Chucky Cheesy.
My cat is fascinated watching you make a cat.
What?
Orange cat?
He's so cute.
OK.
This is Chucky Cheesy.
Is
that OK?
We're gonna be...
We're gonna be an adult.
OK.
My cat meowed at your cat.
My cat meowed back.
OK, guys.
Round face.
Wait,
I need to have a...
How big is my head?
Maybe I need the biggest head.
The Karen cut.
No, I can't change his style.
Guys, I'm gonna be a blonde.
Wait, hold on.
We're gonna... Wait.
This is kind of like...
It's even my colors!
Or should I be black hair?
Because I can be goth mint too.
No, I think... We'll be blonde for now.
We can always go white later.
What's my level of spice tolerance?
Like nothing.
Like zero.
Minus one.
Goth.
Look, it's even my colors.
Let's keep looking through though.
I have a question.
Like, can we...
Can you still get mods and stuff even for this?
But look at this one!
That could look like me.
I could be a ninja!
Ninja!
Mimmy modded hers?
Awesome.
Minky!
If I am like this, would my child be born with a little monkey head?
Questions.
Oh my god, when I would play The Sims, this is what I always put my hair as.
Because this is basically...
Basically, when I was a wee wisp, I wanted the same haircut as Buttercup from the Powerpuff Girls.
And so...
This was my haircut for like...
Way long.
So...
All because of Buttercup.
It's her birthday!
Hello.
Do I take shots of mango, pineapple, vodka, green apple crown, or peach brandy?
Mango pineapple.
I like mango.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Lauren.
Oh, Lauren's old.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday!
Who did I say?
Who did I see say that?
Buttercup is the worst Powerpuff Girl.
Excuse me?
Buttercup was everything to me.
How could you say that?
Factually incorrect.
The Baltimore Symphony Orchestra.
They did a live performance of Raiders of the Lost Ark?
I don't want to go.
Do I have to go to Baltimore or do they...
Will they come to my house?
Why didn't you tell me?
I would have haunted.
Okay, let's be Minky.
Let's do pink Minky.
Clothes.
Oh, wait, no.
Oh, we have to choose.
That's right, this is our everyday look.
And for our fancy look...
I'm being denied Minky access, everybody.
This sucks.
Minky Minky.
Who is the worst Powerpuff Girl?
I don't think there is a worst one.
But if I had to say my least favorite, it would maybe be Blossom.
Probably now that I'm older...
Well, I was like a tomboy, so for me Buttercup was my favorite because I related to Mozart.
Now I think...
Now I think Bubbles might be my favorite.
Let's see.
What should we do for fancy hair?
What is this?
Oh, clown outfit.
Oh, that's nice.
I didn't have any of the expansions when I used to play.
I didn't fumble chat.
I added her weeks ago.
Oh, real clown.
Oh, wow.
That's the actual hair.
Okay, perfect.
This is for fancy occasions.
And then this is for when I'm getting a little freaky.
This is for bedtime.
So always...
Guys, what if my Sim accidentally woohoo's?
Maybe I shouldn't make...
Wait, wait.
I can make... Wait.
What would the child look like?
I want to see the little baby Minky.
Accidental woohooing.
Wait, which is this one?
Oh, this is swimwear.
Swimwear would be...
What
the hell is this forehead?
Why does it look like it expands?
Wait, why does the head actually get bigger?
Wow.
Wow!
Holy cow!
Holy moly!
And then this is athlete.
This is when we're working out.
This is all very true, by the way.
Is this low-def?
There are no accidents.
Yeah, let me control this.
Athletic.
Why can't I only wear my Minky head when I'm...
During my everyday clothes?
I don't understand.
Why am I being denied access?
What's like a sporty cut?
Maybe we should do the hair...
Wait, what's the difference?
Oh, the colors.
We'll do green.
Yeah, we'll do green.
Wow, the largest... This is like actually... Don't raise your eyebrows.
Outerwear.
Perfect.
Let's see.
Let's try and find like a pretty round face.
This is kind of round.
Wait, are those ears?
Are those spiky ears?
It's me!
OK, but I gotta make the face rounder, I think.
I think I have brown cheeks, no?
Like...
Yeah.
Hold on, I'm comparing it.
I'm comparing it.
How close is this?
I can't see.
It's pretty close.
Spot on.
What's the difference?
I could make it bigger.
No, no.
We'll make it normal size.
We'll make it as it was.
And my ears?
Kind of smaller size, but you can't see them right now.
Hold on.
Stung by a bee?
What do you mean?
Hold on.
I need to do this without...
OK, it does kind of look like we're stung by...
Hold on!
No!
What?
It looks like that?
No.
This is...
No, see?
The cheeks are just not...
Look at my cheeks.
My cheeks are up here.
I like hearing the little cat.
So cute.
What if I do this?
Don't smile.
It's creepy.
Does that look better?
Oh wow, it's Minto.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Change the chin?
Oh, do you think the chin is the problem?
I have a pretty pointy chin.
I don't know if I have any...
I need to pull out my 3D reference for this.
Oh wait, here we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is this a peanut?
The forehead is too small.
We literally maxed it out.
Oh, these are eyebrows.
We're not there yet.
Maybe let's get this...
There we go.
Oh my gosh, wait.
It's looking better.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's getting better.
Alright, let's go back.
Oh, whoops.
Let's put our minky back on.
Get your minky on.
That's not bad.
Store so much food for the winter?
Get your minky on.
Why are they so jagged though?
They have pretty thin eyebrows.
Oh, and I'm always like that.
Like that, like that.
We're getting there guys, one step at a time.
My big ol' blue eyes.
See?
It looks just like me.
Why is the face begging for mercy?
No!
My eyes a little...
They slope down.
No, no.
Not that.
I'm pinching those cheeks and pulling...
Stop!
Don't be weird.
Actually, I think just normal is fine.
Oh wait, no, here.
This one.
I see two minkys.
Yeah, you do.
You do.
I saw someone do a challenge where they kept trying to get their character's eyes as big as possible.
Like making each generation bigger and bigger and bigger.
This does work.
Nah, we'll go normal.
This is like...
This is the real...
What just happened?
Why did they go up?
I don't like that.
This is the real RTX, you guys.
Wait, why did they...
This just ruined everything.
No!
Wait, undo.
Okay, there we go.
That ruined everything for a second.
Yeah, I think...
Let's make them a little bit bigger.
Like that.
Her face rippled.
Why does she look so sad?
It's my default.
Maybe.
Okay, we gotta have a little dainty bitty nose.
Everybody knows...
That my nose is so small and delicate because everyone's always saying...
Where's your nose?
Look at that.
Look at that, look at that.
Everybody knows.
Okay, that one wasn't so difficult.
This one is gonna be tricky, I think.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
I want a little Cupid's bow.
How do I make that?
Look at this.
She looks just like me, you know?
Suddenly it worked.
Suddenly it cues.
How did that happen?
Wow, plastic surgery is crazy.
And everyone was so great.
Thank you, Nervous J.
Thank you.
What does it look like without the hat?
Let's test it out.
Really?
This is just for... This is for freaky time.
When we're sleeping... Oh, hold on.
Let me give her some sleep hair.
When she's asleep...
I don't actually put my hair up when I sleep.
But we can do this because she's, you know...
A protective... You know how you can protect your hair when you sleep?
You guys like ponytails?
And
this is when she's working out.
Oh, no.
This is when she's working out.
This is when she's swimming.
She got some Ariana Grande extensions in.
She looks concerned.
No, she's okay.
I think we got it, guys.
I think we got it.
Oh, she needs makeup.
Oh, that's so thick.
Oh, this is the blush.
What do you call that?
The highlighter crazy.
I don't really have eyeshadow.
Oh, it's kind of dark.
We are in goth mode.
Maybe we go for a gothy look.
Maybe we go for a goth look.
Have you guys noticed I do have...
Oh, sorry.
I didn't realize it would stop the music.
Do you guys see?
You see my lips?
I do have a bit of gloss on.
You see it?
It's shiny.
We need something to match that.
Really?
They don't have anything?
Everything is so bright.
Why is everything so bright?
Oh my god.
Show your lips really close and also get close to the mic, please.
Time to get mods.
For real, I've never done mods.
This one is not bad.
This one is not so bad.
I've never done mods with the Sims.
I'm scared.
Maybe we'll have to for next time.
Oh, mods for chat.
Chat mods.
This is an average Sunday, no?
You guys are just joking around.
Wait, what's this?
Wow, we have jewelry.
Guys, if you ever see me wearing earrings...
They're clip-ons.
If you ever see me wearing jewelry, it's clip-on earrings.
I don't have my ears pierced.
Bracelet.
A little butterfly.
We're going for a gothy look.
None of these are gothy at all.
This one I like.
We'll go for that.
It's very anime.
What are you saying?
Right there?
There's like nothing there.
The gold is nice.
Reminds me of something, but I can't remember what.
Oh my goodness.
Can you even see?
Oh, you can see the necklace.
Wow, these are all really hideous.
This is all you get.
Imagine you paid for this DLC and this is what they provide you.
What the heck is that?
Oh, it's awful.
And then a shark tooth.
That's not even a shark tooth.
What is that?
Flat 2D texture.
It is.
Maybe I should have it because it's just like me.
Flat.
We'll go with the fish tooth.
Oh, a ring.
They all look the same.
Oh, we got a cool thumb ring.
So that my finger shines when I do a thumbs up.
What's this?
Oh my gosh, we're blinged out.
How many can I have?
Oh, there we go.
We're blinged out.
Nice.
And we did the makeup.
And eyebrow style.
Oh, I like these ones.
They're like more natural now.
My eyebrows are anime eyebrows, so...
Hmm...
Honestly, these ones might... Oh, you can't see it.
These ones might fit more, but...
What do you mean you forgot to have eyebrows?
They're right here.
Sorry, every time I click out of the game, it stops the music.
Let's just go with this one.
I think it works better.
Okidoki, and our clothing.
Oh my gosh, maid outfit.
Wear, wear.
Oh my gosh, what if I had a crop top on?
Scandalous!
Oh my gosh.
Woah.
Woah!
That's for night on the town.
Wait, there's no maid outfit.
Wait, maybe under this.
Why wouldn't there be a maid outfit?
Oh, this is close.
That's close.
Oh, this one's cute.
Oh wait, this is pretty close too.
This is pretty close.
Oh my gosh, I look like a...
50's housewife.
I wish I could change the color though.
Dang, she's feeling herself in the clown.
No way, maid outfit.
Konnichiwa.
We're only halfway through.
There's definitely going to be a maid outfit in here.
Bye.
Guys, do you see that?
Woah, look at the mirror.
Holy moly, this might be actually...
Why is this one like one of the sexiest outfits?
Why is it unironically so sexy?
Oh, I'm Mrs. Claus.
We don't want that.
We want a maid.
Oh, but what if I'm a little...
Holy underboob.
What?
They're allowed to do that.
Underboob.
Wow.
Those coconuts are struggling.
Wait, what is... The butt looks so good.
See, the butt looks whatever in this.
That looks like what I have to wear when I do 3D.
That's like what I have to do when I become 3D.
There really are no maid outfits.
This is so sad.
Let's go back to this one.
Guys, I don't know if I'm feeling the monkey head anymore.
It's throwing off my vibe.
Let's go back to hair.
And my everyday outfit.
Let's go with...
Wait, oh my gosh.
Wait, does this actually match?
Wait, this one.
It matches.
Oh my gosh.
That's...
The ears are killing me.
Oh here, hold on.
There we go.
They are the
same picture.
So that's our everyday outfit and then this is our form...
Wait, where did this hair come from?
What?
Who are you?
Our formal outfit.
Where is the kimono?
Wait, this could be the formal outfit.
What happened to the hair?
Holy...Wow!
Cheetah.
Cheetah print.
What?
Wow.
Gyaru?
Okay, we can be a gyaru.
But seriously, what happened to the hair?
Now it's not letting me...Oh here we go.
When did I choose this?
With the top hat obviously.
We are so dapper.
Don't look.
It's not for your eyes.
Oh my goodness.
I'm going to give her some granny panties.
So that you guys...
You guys can't get too excited.
Oh wait, I can give her actual shorts.
Oh wait, this is kind of my color.
Or I can just cover her up entirely.
This one is so sexy though.
You guys can't see.
You guys are missing a good show.
Hello.
It's a mirror.
Oh no!
Anyway,
let's go to sleepwear.
Gosh.
I usually...I'm not going to lie.
That looks dirty though.
Why is it so dirty and gross?
I sometimes wear pajamas like this.
My little...I call them...
I call them my lumberjacks.
These are usually dirty.
Not like this.
This is awful.
This is so bad.
But I like wearing comfy t-shirts and pants.
That's what I wear.
People who wear stuff like this, I'm like, how do you do that?
Well, sometimes, you know.
Unless I'm like naked.
I only like to do that if I'm so hot.
Swimsuit!
Okay, what's our closest to a Tsukumizu?
Maybe this.
Maybe that.
Or this.
Actually, this might be the best one.
I don't really go swimming.
Neither will my Sim.
It's music.
This is our athletic outfit.
How is this?
Oh, it's like a tennis outfit.
I see.
Wait!
Oh my gosh!
You guys!
Look at that!
It's perfect!
It's absolutely perfect.
Perfect.
Nice.
And then this is our outerwear.
Maybe we can find...
Oh, this is so cute, actually.
Oh my gosh, it's so stinking cute.
Puffy jacket is kind of cute, too.
I like this one.
I'm going to eat some more of my salad.
Hold on.
I don't want to get kind of gross and all.
You like the look?
OK, we'll go with this.
What
are my goals?
What is a pleasure aspiration?
Love wild nights out.
Cozy nights in.
They would want the good life.
But I...
Fortune, money baby, money.
Fortune and glory.
But I think only the romance wants to woohoo.
Three woohoos.
What about knowledge?
Why can't I be a...
Well...
Maybe knowledge.
I don't think ask for homework help should be so big.
Zodiac stuff so well?
I don't remember which one I am.
October 1st, which one am I, you guys?
But we shall...
We shall determine my personality.
So I think I'm a little more neat than sloppy.
But I'm not entirely neat.
Looks in the mirror, plus 3000 aspiration.
A Libra.
Max out sloppy.
No!
When it comes to being shy.
I know it's classic Sims BGM.
I
think I'm like in between active and lazy.
Oh wait.
Wait.
That would be in between.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
That's in between.
There we go.
I think I'm like in between.
Sometimes I'm kind of lazy.
I think I'm also maybe like...
Wow.
Oh no.
I'm not nice at all.
I'm a cancer.
I'm too grouchy.
I'm very grouchy then.
Maybe I will take off some from me.
I don't know though.
It's kind of weird being like... Oh my gosh guys.
I'm so nice.
Guys, I'm just so nice.
Oh my gosh.
One less playful?
You think so?
What?
Where is Libra?
This one.
Oh.
I don't fit that at all.
No.
That's mean.
In between.
Maybe like that?
Less neat?
What are you talking about?
You don't...You don't come to my maid cafe.
You don't know...You don't know what my room looks like.
You don't know.
There is cobwebs.
Oh for atmosphere?
I want to go with a get rich.
I want to actually maybe create a multi-level marketing.
And make it big and rich.
So my turn on is...
Full face of makeup.
Vampires?
That's a good one.
Underwear.
Dang.
What?
Like how I can just be like...
Snake in a tux.
Little age soldiers.
Stop it.
Jewelry.
I was like married?
That would be pretty messed up.
Charismatic.
Oh my gosh.
I love when they are unemployed.
I can't believe.
I can't...Wait.
Shouldn't underwear just be a given?
No?
Are there people that have a turn off to underwear?
Who says someone in their underwear and is like...
Put it back on.
I never would have seen that.
Nudists.
Oh they don't want anything.
Sports.
Yuck.
What is that?
Plant-simism.
Here's my investment in Domingo's pyramid scheme.
No, no.
It's a multi-level marketing.
It's not a pyramid scheme.
It might be pyramid shaped.
But actually we call it a triangle of wisdom.
Okay, so we have robots and we have...
You know what?
I'm going to say formal wear.
That is the truth.
And then, what is this?
Oh, cologne.
My turn off is...
Underwear.
What is this one?
Oh, stink.
Oh, custom hair.
What is this one?
Logical, okay.
A construction worker?
I hate when they are creative.
Wait, why does it feel like there is...
Oh, because of the two that I just added.
I can't make them a turn off.
I
don't want a zombie.
Because I'm a ghost and we kind of fight with undead.
I'm dead, but I'm here.
And then zombies are dead, but they are there.
And it just kind of is like...
We are just always beefing.
It's just kind of annoying.
Yeah, pretty awkward.
Yeah, yeah, so...
That's my turn off.
A zombie.
Makes sense.
The Dorito of wisdom.
Everybody...
Why does she look like that?
Say hello to Miss Cheesy.
Alright.
I'm going to make Matara now.
Matara is going to be my roommate.
We also can't do...
We'll do...
What's the close...
Maybe this is the close...
Orange is like the closest to pink, no?
Oh yeah, my bad.
Oh my gosh, if I become a grandma I can change my hair.
I see.
It doesn't matter if it's orange or not.
Fine, I'll make her an adult.
Okay, Matara's hair is...
Hold on, let me get a picture of her.
Actually, I'm going to make her a witch because that's what she is.
With a B.
Yeah.
Or, we can do this and we'll never have to see her face.
We could give her...
Oh my gosh, Matara-Kan.
You're so cute.
I'm debating.
Oh wait.
She had her little...
Wait, this is actually so perfect.
She had her commander outfit.
So, actually we can do this one.
That works.
That actually works.
Yeah, she has a commander hat.
Matara's eye color, what is it, yellow?
Oh, wait a second.
Is she going to get mad at me for this?
Hold on.
One moment, please.
Sorry, hold on.
But...
Remember when we played PT?
Okay, okay.
Red eyes.
How can I do that?
I possessed her for just a moment.
I possessed her for just a second.
Don't tell her.
We'll go with...
What should we do since we can't go with...
Maybe brown?
Worst eye color.
Say the thing.
Hi, honeys.
Oh, I'm Matara-Kan.
Dude.
I feel gross.
I need a shower.
I'm going to change back.
I'm going to change back!
Goodbye, Matara.
There we go.
Nice.
Alrighty.
And let's give her some actual bug eyes, you know?
I think that would be good for her, truly.
You can go tell Matara that to her face.
I
don't want to see any of your confessions to Matara-Kan.
Reject him as Matara?
No.
It's okay.
Okay.
So, her eyes are, like, always kind of...
Oh no, she's actually...
Her eyes are, like, yeah...
They're, like, really sharp, you know?
They're really sharp.
She does got bug eyes, though.
I mean, they are pretty big.
Is Matara gone already?
I went and grabbed my ring.
Yeah, she's gone!
She's gone!
Look, she says, I don't want to talk to you anymore.
My name is Matara-Kan.
You're trying to propose to me?
I don't want to talk to you anymore.
Don't smile.
Nah,
I think, actually, this is kind of perfect.
What's her nose?
She's got an even smaller nose.
This looks like she smelled something bad.
Yes, Matara-Kan.
Yes.
Oh, maybe I should have switched my lips up.
This actually looks so good.
I actually look so much like her.
She got them crazy lashes.
She got a little... Actually, well, she's got, like...
Okay, perfect!
Oh my gosh!
Snake!
Remember how I said my turn-off was zombie?
Wait!
This is so perfect!
Oh my gosh!
This is actually so perfect.
It's her!
It's literally her.
What the hell are these?
Oh wait, the commander outfit.
Oh my god, this is also old school music.
I thought you could adjust, like, their boobs and stuff in this game, no?
Everyone has the same body shape?
How do I still remember?
I don't know.
When she said ba-ba-ba, I felt it in my heart.
I told you, I really liked this game.
Oh my gosh, this is so...
Wait, you guys are gonna get too excited over this, I think.
It is really her.
Don't get too excited.
Remember whose stream you're watching.
Remember whose stream you're watching!
Why would everything look so sexy on her?
Fine, we'll keep this.
I don't see, like, the military outfit that goes with the hat.
Did you guys see it or did I pass it?
I think you guys...
Yeah.
Sorry, I don't have a big boobie.
I
don't have a big boobie because I am a boob.
Simple as.
Oh my gosh.
I thought that was...
Wait.
Oh, there it is!
The commander outfit.
It's just literally a sailor though.
Nah, we'll go with the other one.
I thought it was a Robin Hood outfit, that one.
You have big booty.
Nah, we'll go with this.
The clown.
Wow, her formal outfit.
This one, obvious.
Oh my gosh, it's so much like her normal outfit.
We have to go with this one.
Her undies.
Doesn't she canonically have underwear?
We'll go with the black.
Actually, no, this one is sexier.
She's gonna be so sexy.
Everybody is gonna be like...
Oh, Matara-con.
Matara-cheesy.
Matara-cheesy-con.
I've come to propose to you.
Nobody's gonna go ask out.
Sad Minto.
Oh my gosh, sexy.
We'll go with the pink.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is so cute.
Oh my gosh, this is so cute.
Wait.
This one is my favorite.
It's so cute.
Nah, I like it in purple better.
I already rejected Matara.
What do you mean you rejected her?
What do you mean?
What if we did...
Oh my gosh, wait.
What if with Matara we had the 100 baby challenge?
Do you think we could?
We gotta give her the Baywatch outfit or whatever she wants.
The wise man once said, flat is justice and medium is premium.
This one.
This is what she wants.
And then, for her athletic wear.
It's so cute.
Huh?
You guys don't know the Sims 100 baby challenge?
100 husband challenge.
I wonder how many husbands she could kill.
Oh, I forgot to change her hair.
For like all her other outfits.
This, oh wait.
We'll go with just down.
100 killed husbands, yeah.
I've seen that fan art.
Fan art what?
Oh wait, no, this is not night time, sorry.
At night, she takes off her wig.
Wait, what did I just do?
Yeah, this is fine.
Actually, this all works, honestly.
And
then for her outdoors.
You guys, you thought that orange was natural?
Heck no.
Miss cheesy, everything's pink.
Everything, she is so easy because there's so much pink.
There's so much pink everything.
Easy peasy.
All right, Matara's personality.
So we're going to give her the romance aspiration because she's always wanting husbands.
And she's kind of...
She's extremely outgoing.
She's active.
She's playful.
I wonder if she's actually a Leo.
Does this seem accurate to you guys?
If you know Matara.
Is Mata nice?
Yeah, she's a cockroach, so she's got to be max sloppy.
And she's like crazy outgoing.
And she's pretty active.
And she's really playful, but she can be serious.
All right, what are Matara...
Okay, knowing Matara...
I don't know if I've ever...
I don't know if we've ever had this con...
I'm sure she's mentioned it to me before.
Probably, just like what her type is.
Is this what... hats?
Oh my god.
What if it turned on his hat?
Hats.
Oh yeah, that hat really gets me going.
Oh yeah, keep it on.
Keep it on.
Do you have two players?
Matara probably likes fitness.
She does work out, unemployed and hat.
Oh yeah, maybe she's pretty like...
You know, maybe underwear...
Oh, cologne.
Oh, this one's the smell.
Wait, what if her turn on is stink?
What if she likes a little bit of smelliness?
Oh, because she's a cockroach.
She's a cockroach, so of course she's going to be like attracted to the garbage.
That just makes sense.
Okay.
And then her turn off would be...
Good at cleaning.
Because she's a cockroach.
And you get cockroaches if you are too good at cleaning.
Stink.
Pretty sure she said she likes guy smell.
I
don't want to think about it.
She did?
Oh my god.
Maybe she likes cologne?
Or is it like...
Guy, guy smell.
Like the meme.
Like, guy smell.
Guy smell.
Mata is Eva.
Boy smell.
Wow, boy smell.
I'm judging a little.
Well, only because it's Matara I'm judging.
Why are they staring at each other?
It's the mask?
Oh my god, her eyes just rolled into the back of her head.
Okay, so our relationship.
This is my cat.
Wait, how do I make my cat?
Okay, nevermind.
So we're roomies!
We're roomies!
Okay guys.
I'm gonna strike it rich and make it big.
And then Matara is going to woohoo for 100 babies.
They were roommates.
Wow, they were roommates.
Now, we're not quite done.
Because we have to also make our rival family.
Which will include Snake.
This is the solid family.
We're making Snake.
Snake and Otacon!
Wait, what if I scramble?
What if we just happen to get the perfect Snake?
Hold on, I'm going to close my eyes.
I
want to beef with this family.
You know, I kind of want to have a family where we're always at each other's throats.
And it's just like, no!
I will never let you come upon my land!
I will literally shoot you dead!
Real America moment.
You better be about to make the same guy four times and then Osolat.
Let's see.
Okay, I give up.
These all suck.
Oh my gosh!
This is a good starting point.
Alright.
Solid Snake.
Oh my gosh!
He already has the headband!
Wait, this is also a headband.
Can one house be Otacon and Naomi?
Oh wait!
What if we do make Naomi and have our place be spewed with her?
Aki, happy birthday!
Thank you for always being a huge source of happiness for me.
Thank you so much!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Aki!
Happy birthday!
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Plissken.
Okay.
Wait.
I can't do this.
I can't...
It's too...
He looks too good.
Let's make our house.
Okay, hold on.
How much money do we have, Matara?
How much money do we have?
Matara.
Oh, we have 25,000 simoleons.
We're gonna move here.
And I'm gonna build us a house, baby.
Guys...
How do I use cheats?
Why are we in the middle of the ocean?
Oh my god!
My cat is so cute!
Oh my... Give love.
Give love.
Feed treat.
Feed treat to Chucky Cheesy.
No cheating good, because we're having to build a house.
Oh, Matara's bird watching.
Okay.
How do I bring it?
Oh, CTRL-SHIFT-C.
Thank you!
Alright, this is just to build our house.
This is just to build our house, everybody.
We gotta even out the land.
Wait, did that even it?
Wait.
Oh no, that pushed it.
Undo.
Up.
Bring it up.
No!
Why is it so high?
There we go.
Nice.
Oh my gosh, it's so bumpy!
It's so bumpy!
How do I... How do I... How can I tell?
Oh, it's so bumpy.
Okay, they're just gonna have to have a little bit of an unconventional space.
Now, we're gonna give a bit of a yard.
Let's give it a little bit of, you know, let's give it a little bit of character.
What if I have it in the shape of something?
Oh wait, I'm gonna make it... Oh, because it's Mint and Vitara...
I'm gonna make it in the shape of an M!
Wait.
Oh, diagonal, diagonal, diagonal is kind of crazy.
Location out of bounds?
What are you talking about?
How is that out of bounds?
Build the foundation first.
What do you mean?
Do I have to do that?
Build the foundation?
I
don't think you needed foundation.
Maybe it'll help.
I don't know why this is technically... Why is this out of bounds?
You just have to be two tiles away.
Oops, I forgot a piece here.
It's a flavor wall.
Okay, hold on.
So we're gonna have to... I'm gonna keep it just because...
It'll help me keep track.
Alright.
Need something to support it.
Alright, there we go.
M.
Oh my god, so close.
Alright, one more.
There we go.
Nice.
This is the entrance.
Doorway.
Right here.
So one half will be hers.
And one half will be mine.
You get it?
Oh yeah!
You might be wondering...
Well Minto, what goes on outside here?
We can build something else.
A
patio?
Oh yeah.
What's this?
Half wall?
What's the difference between these?
What are these for?
Timeout rooms?
Yeah, these are the pods.
Actually, I'm gonna make like...
Why can't I make it any bigger?
We're gonna make two.
One for me, one for her.
His and her pod room.
Idea.
Microwave hallway?
Like love is blind?
Oh my gosh, kind of.
But then... So this is the only way that we'll be able to get to each other's parts of the house.
Because it's gonna be connected.
And it's gonna be like that.
Bulldoze.
Sledgehammer?
There we go.
Ooh!
Oh, Artemis!
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you, thank you!
Oh yeah, we'll need two entrances, but that's just how it is, you know?
There we go.
Perfect.
Why can't... What do you mean I can't build diagonally?
That is literally what I've been doing this entire time.
What are you talking about?
I can't build diagonally.
I'll just do it like that.
Okay, so this is the only way that they can have access to each other.
Oh wait, it's kind of off-center, but that's okay.
See, we'll have one door here.
Oh no!
You know my hole is in the ground.
Undo.
Wait, it's control?
Yes.
Okay, I remember.
Oh my gosh, I remembered, I remembered.
It's a little off-center.
I'm gonna give myself more room than her.
And so she gets a door.
And I get a door.
Just like that.
So nice!
Oh my gosh, the Mintamatora household.
We'll have this area at last.
There's some windows in here.
Do you think it'd be weird if she could see into my side of the house?
Looks like a folded shirt.
I don't see it.
I wish there was a one-way mirror so that I could look into hers.
Actually, I don't want to see what she's doing in there.
I actually would much prefer to have no knowledge of what she's doing at all.
What is this?
Whoa, what is this?
Great gate door.
Why does it say H&M on it?
What is this product placement?
Build a balcony over Matara's side?
That's a great idea!
Oh my gosh!
That's such a good idea.
My
gosh!
That's such a good idea.
Okay, okay.
How do I do this though?
Let's put some... Wait, hold on.
Let's put some flooring down first.
Alright.
Matara has dreams of Hollywood, so...
We'll put like that.
We'll put a little... Oh, these are all tiles.
Okay, there's more.
Okay, cool.
Oh, basketball court!
That one's for me!
Wait, how do I make it so that it doesn't go outside?
Okay, we're playing b-ball in my room.
Because it's like...
You know.
What is this anyway?
Dinosaurs?
If it was dinosaurs, I was about to change it to me.
Okay, is this grass?
Oh, it's carpet.
I wonder if they have dinosaurs.
I have to have you guys... Oh my gosh.
Okay, so one of the funniest things is happening.
Right now.
On TikTok.
The dinosaur community is like all up in arms.
Because they're so mad that the Spinosaurus keeps getting debuffed.
Have you guys seen what the Spinosaurus looks like anymore?
It's so sad.
He's got like this...
He's got like this floppy nose now.
And everyone's so mad because he looks so ugly.
But they keep buffing the T-Rex.
And basically at this point they're like...
Yeah, the T-Rex has like...
He's got...
He's got lasers shooting out of his eyes.
And he's crazy.
Wait, how do I do it so it's only within the walls?
Everyone's up in arms about it.
The poor Spinosaurus.
The Spinosaurus Discord is in shambles.
Oh, shift click.
Thank you!
Oh!
I don't want it like that.
Or maybe.
Wait, is this like an optical illusion?
Sticky stacker floors.
What should be the...
Oh, it should be like a road because it's like a...
You know.
Wait, I wish I could make it...
Wait, can I change which direction it's in?
We'll make it like this then.
It's like a little through, you know?
T-Rex chasers keep winning.
No!
The idea of new research being presented as video game patch notes is amazing and more people should do it.
It's so funny because people...
You have the people that are like...
They keep nerfing my guy!
What are they doing to the Spinosaurus?
And then you have other people who are just like...
Guys, this is like science.
You can't just...
You can't debuff a creature if that's how he's...
If that's how he looks.
That's just how he looks.
And they're like...
No!
They debuffed him!
So it's pretty funny...
How people have been so upset about it.
T-Rex, new with bionic arms, laser eyes.
Yes!
Fire breath.
That's like what they keep doing to him.
Alright.
Well, maybe I gave them too much money.
Okay, they might have to like play the lotto or something and...
Lose it all, you know?
What is this?
Ew, it looks so gross!
Cement.
What's this?
How do you get that to work?
lol
Modern and sophisticated, I like it.
Jetpack not available on all platforms.
We still don't know what to put in here yet though.
We'll figure it out.
Okay.
Oh, upstairs.
It's nice and pink because we're going to overlook Matara Khan.
Pass.
No, it's boots and cats!
It's cool you are following up last year's podcast with your own reality show.
I know!
What kind of hijinks will they get into?
And a little border.
Wait.
Actually...
It's like circles, squares, circles.
Many circles.
It's good.
Wait, what did I just do?
Is this not supposed to be a square?
Oh, diagonal.
Oops.
Oh my gosh, I just Ctrl-Zed and it worked.
Room.
Okay, we're just going to have to put this.
Oh wait, but we don't need it here.
Yeah.
Nice and open.
Wait.
This has a rooftop.
Oh, half wall, half wall.
Wait, no?
How do I make the half wall?
You can put out railing.
I can?
How so?
Like this?
And our rooftop.
Hey, where is the roof here?
Why does this actually look so good?
Wait, why does this actually work so well?
Wait.
I want this not to have a roof though.
Like in the middle.
It doesn't look like an M anymore.
A balcony, I think I need to have the wall here for it to have a roof.
Remove roof.
Okay, what I'm just going to do is I'm just going to make it walls.
It'll make it kind of creepier, but that's okay.
Oh, wait, I did it!
Oh, wait.
Oh wait, how will I look into Matara's room?
Wait, how do I look into Matara's room?
Make the wall taller.
Build a second floor and just leave it open to below.
Is that not what I did?
Make a glass floor.
Can I?
Looking for glass.
We're looking for glass.
So I have to build the Matara side to be taller.
I see, I see, I see.
Okay, okay.
I think that would probably be the easiest way to do it.
I think you guys are smart.
Wait, so she's going to get more head space than me?
There we go.
That's kind of messed up.
It didn't work.
Um...
Wait, what just happened?
Undo.
There we go.
Delete the roof.
Oh, I can make my own roof.
I
don't know why it's...
Why it doesn't work.
I haven't saved.
Thank you.
There we go.
Let's save.
Go up one more floor.
Auto roof!
Now!
What did I do wrong?
The gap in the...
Oh, maybe if I'm like...
If I do...
Like this?
Like
that?
What a shape.
It looks
nice, no?
And then, one thing I'm going to try and do...
Okay, one thing I want to try and do...
Is make this out doors.
Let's see, maybe we just do this.
Maybe I just remove the foundation.
Wait, remove.
There we go.
Back to dirt.
Modern art.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have objections to this house?
No, where?
Where's the bathroom?
We haven't put any furniture in yet.
Not yet.
Okay, I can't get it quite perfect.
It's like so dark in there, no?
I don't want the roof so that there's nothing...
You know what I mean?
I'm struggling a little bit here.
I guess we could do that.
Where's the pool?
Oh, here it is.
Curved edge.
Swimming pool.
What's this?
What's the difference?
I can't...
Oh, wait.
Oh, we'll need the foundation back.
I suppose.
Oh, it's only allowed on terrain.
Okay, undo, undo, undo.
Wait.
Redo, redo, redo.
Wait, what's going on?
Wait, what did I just do?
How did that happen?
Wait.
Guys, I think I messed up.
Okay.
I also just realized we're on the second store...
Wait, no.
This is fine.
It's the foundation.
Foundation.
I should have never put foundation.
It's ruining my plans.
Oh, wait.
We need to put a door.
This music is making me crazy.
Oh, no.
Oh, we can have a tree.
No, we can't.
Must be placed outside.
It is outside.
What are they talking about?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
What do you mean I can't extend the pool?
What am I doing?
Okay, we're done.
What do you mean?
Okay.
One at a time.
We're getting it.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Cool.
I might need a...
like a staircase into it.
So let's get rid of some of this foundation.
Again.
Foundation sucks.
I'm never putting it ever.
Ever, ever again.
There we go.
Just like that.
Is it getting confused by the second floor?
I don't know.
I'm like, there shouldn't be...
a roof right here, which is annoying me a little bit.
I get why it's doing it, but I don't know how to remove it.
Let's see, maybe I can remove it with my own hands.
It's happening!
We're doing it, we're doing it.
Okay, now I have to add some roof.
Let's add like this.
Oh wow.
Oh my god!
Oh wait, I removed so much roof.
Okay, hold on.
Undo.
I don't think that can fit.
That's so sad.
This one looks like a nose.
Gosh.
Being an architect is so hard.
Make a flat one.
Oh, can I?
Like this?
Wait, what do you mean it can't intersect with other objects?
Is the round one too much in the way?
It can't intersect.
That's why they get paid well.
I think I'm in the wrong business.
I'm in the wrong stinking business here.
What is it intersecting with?
Why doesn't it just merge with the other roof?
Okay, hold on.
Like here.
See?
The stairs?
It's
my birthday.
I wish Miki the best and please...
Please what?
Haunt me!
Thank you for the Akasuba!
Thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Ian!
Happy birthday!
Okay, I give up.
Architecture?
What have I been doing this entire time if not that?
Wait, is this a stage?
Oh, what is it?
Oh my gosh!
What is this?
We can make a...
We can make like a skate ramp.
And doors.
What is this?
There's so much here.
Oh, that's how I turn things.
That's right.
Oops, oops, oops, oops.
Too much turn.
Too much turning.
There's
a way to do this.
Yes, yes.
And we'll give Matara this.
Okay.
So we want some windows.
Big window looking out front.
Me looking out to the side.
Me looking at Matara.
Why isn't this one so dark in here still?
I don't get it.
This is so cute.
Cute.
You guys said last time there were not enough windows, so...
You're welcome.
You said...
Mito, this sucks.
There's not enough windows.
Are the windows looking at the pool?
Oh yeah, we need those, don't we?
Can you do diagonal?
Oh nice.
How do we get to the pool?
Maybe from this right here.
There's a little door right here and then we have a stair.
Oh wait, maybe we do a ladder.
Actually, how do we do it?
How do you get in?
Diving board from the second floor?
That's ridiculous.
That's insanity.
Actually, let's start making our houses.
This is the kitchen.
My kitchen.
Oh, must place under counter.
Okay, I'll put a counter.
Okay,
alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright, alright.
Wow, I think I gave him too much money.
I think I might have given him too much money.
Because there's like a lot.
Alright, Matara loves to cook everybody.
This is just Matara's way of expressing that.
Mito is the one to fill this dark house with wine.
Ceiling light.
This looks like cookies.
Oh my god, it really lights up the room, huh?
That's so cool.
Wow, the b-ball court is so crazy.
Oh, they need beds, don't they?
Okay, wait, this is bed.
Matara is on her way to 100 woohoo's.
She may regret them.
Why?
Why would I regret the light?
Why would I regret those?
What is this?
We cannot have that.
Especially for Matara.
Because she is not impregnable.
I would wish bad luck.
Actually, I'll take this one though.
What should they do for fun?
Bonsen.
So big.
Is this archery?
Oh, it's axe throwing.
What?
Must be placed outside.
What's this one?
Crafting it.
Formicarium.
I don't want to give too much stuff.
We'll figure it out later.
She's going to build her husband.
I'm officially an uncle!
Kizora, you're an uncle.
What do uncles do?
What's like a real uncle-y type of thing?
What's an uncle thing?
Congratulations!
Drink and watch football.
Is that not a dad?
Can't anybody do that technically?
Okay, I kind of hate this wall.
It's limiting me.
It's limiting my success.
What is this?
Oh, it's a bone rug.
Matara needs a bunch of these.
Alright, Matara.
Subliminal messaging.
Alright,
Matara.
You know what to do.
You know what to do, girlfriend.
I think we need some plants for some life in this place.
It's so dead in here.
We need a little bit of life.
And everything.
I'll figure out how to use the pool.
I will figure it out.
It's not Christmas.
What am I doing?
Wait, can I build a snowman?
That's so cute.
What am I missing?
Oh, bathroom.
They'll want...
I don't want to get robbed.
We need phones.
One on each side.
Take your time.
Thank you!
It's been so long since I've played this game.
But we're figuring it out.
We're getting pretty good.
Let me save real quick.
And then a bathroom.
Wait.
Oh, bathroom.
Here we go.
Oh, and a shower.
Oh my gosh, how could I forget?
Give her some privacy.
Ooh, fancy.
Not fancy.
And, oh, a sink.
Let's do a sink so that they can wash their hands.
And their stuff.
How do I make it into the counter?
You know what?
It's fine.
We'll just do this.
And then also...
Do this.
Are we good to go?
A karaoke machine?
We can get that.
That sounds so fun.
Where would it be?
Karaoke, karaoke, karaoke.
What the hell is this?
Electro dance sphere.
I want to try it.
We have a fridge for each person.
You should give them a coffee machine for the caffeine.
We could do that.
I think Minto is missing a few countertops, no?
Which one did I give her before?
This one.
Coffee machine.
What is this?
The main squeezer.
Espresso.
That's not me.
Switch it up like Nintendo.
I don't see karaoke.
Dresser.
Switch it up like Minto.
We can't afford a car.
That's okay.
Maybe someday.
What is this?
Can she play with that or is it for babies only?
I'll put it on Matara's side.
Alright, alright.
Oh wait, the cat, the cat, the cat.
Cat needs stuff.
The cat, the cat, the cat.
Cat needs litter box.
Cat needs bowl.
Cat needs...
What is this?
Dog pen, no?
Bed.
Okay, that should be it.
That should be good.
Shall we play?
Back to...
Stop!
Unstop time!
What did we just fulfill?
Wait, we just fulfilled something.
What is it?
No, no!
What happened?
Alright, Minto needs to go potty.
Try out your new toilet.
It's really fancy.
They have stairs.
Oopsie, I messed up.
How?
Oh shoot.
Wait, how do they get inside?
Wait.
Wait,
staircase.
But it doesn't work.
How do they get inside?
I should have never done the foundation.
I'm a fool!
Why did I do that?
Oh my gosh.
Use mini stairs.
These?
Connecting stairs, railing...
There is no mini stairs!
What we could do is this.
Connecting stairs?
Will that work?
I tried it, but it didn't do anything.
See?
Maybe I have to be here?
Like this?
Maybe?
What is this?
What's happening?
It went down.
NTR house?
What are you talking about?
No.
On the foundation itself.
It won't let me.
Can't place bottom landing.
Maybe it's the tile?
Let's try this.
No!
Guys, I messed up.
Wait, what the heck is this?
Where did this come from?
I don't know what to do.
Delete portions of the foundation.
The staircase is too long.
Wait, foundation.
Like that.
And then we do the stair.
Oh my god, it works!
Thank you!
I was so scared for a second.
It worked!
Oh my gosh, I remember in the old game.
You used to be able to go to the top of the screen and it would move.
But now I have to right click everything.
How are you doing Matara?
Oh you also have to go to the bathroom.
Go into your own house.
And Cheezy.
Cheezy is going in!
There he goes!
They each have their own side.
No Cheezy no!
Cheezy no!
That's my bed Cheezy!
Cheezy!
Don't destroy the...
I like how Cheezy walked up to Minto to get scolded.
No!
Destroying the furniture!
Oh my god, Matara is already coming over.
What are you doing?
I don't want you over here in my house.
Get out of here!
And now she hates it!
What do you mean?
Why are you complaining?
It's not your house.
We have a Mr. Humble here.
Minto is throwing up on the carpet, but she got some gains.
Monty!
So cute!
OK, Matara, you go.
We are going to have you... Oh, open up the present.
What is this?
We have the garden club coming over.
Hello Tiffany.
Oh my god, it's...
She knocked and then...
What did you give us?
Oh, a computer!
Thank you!
Wait, talk to this lady.
What's up?
Why does everyone hate the orb?
Look, she already has a woohoo.
Tiffany is into it.
Oh my god!
Tiffany is into it!
Why did she just do that?
No Cheesy, no!
No Chucky Cheesy!
I think they are going to be into it.
Is she woohoo with the grandma?
I don't think it's going to happen guys.
What does licknarb mean?
Where are you going?
Tell a joke?
This lady just invited herself into our house.
Excuse me ma'am.
The Sims is crazy.
I'm going to get rid of this wall.
I can't see anything.
You know?
Like all this.
I can't see anything.
It's blocking it.
It's so ugly.
You can lock doors?
I can?
Lock the door.
Oh, go here?
Did she just salute like she's a captain?
Oh no, you have to make some food!
Make a group meal.
She's going to make mac and cheese.
No, don't read.
Don't do that.
Praise for yowling.
Who the hell are you?
Jenny Smith?
Everybody is coming...
Why does everyone look like this?
Everybody is so slouchy.
Why are they like this?
Why is everybody so slouchy?
Why is everybody at our house?
I'm going to have... I'm going to have you make a robot.
Wait, only a toy robot?
You think she'll still like it?
Customize my robot.
What should the robot's name be?
Zombie?
No, he's an alien.
Zeke?
Rex?
Rex Robot.
Metal Gear reference.
Lady just used my toilet.
Get out of here.
Go away Tiffany.
How is Matara doing?
She's cooking.
She's cooking well.
Crabs?
No, it's mac and cheese.
It's not crabs.
So buy a sculpture costing at least that much.
A painting.
Can she dance here?
No.
Another cat.
Sake the cat.
She's really into making that robot.
Do not let her cook.
It's horrible.
She finished it!
Time to eat.
I think she's throwing up.
I think she's saying it's really horrible.
She finished it though.
I didn't mean to do that.
I want to greet the cat.
Is the cat still here?
Who the hell are you?
She is a good friend.
She's walking all the way over here.
This lady is still here.
Tiffany, go home.
This is not your retirement home.
Please.
Hot lady.
I'm supposed to say hello to Michelle.
Hello Michelle.
Okay.
Propose?
Give?
Pet?
No, I'm not giving up Chucky.
Why would I do that?
Tiffany's children don't...
We are going to entertain her with a joke.
I think we just did that.
Oh my gosh, we are a natural comedian.
Oh.
How does this thing exercise you?
Have I drowned anyone in the pool yet?
I can't get to the pool.
Oh wait!
Now I know how to build the stairs.
Oh it's not big enough.
Oh no!
I messed up!
What do I do?
I make the pool smaller.
That will fix it.
That will fix the problem.
No more pool here.
Get rid of the pool.
They need a way to swim.
Like that.
Nice.
Get rid of the pool.
Let's delete ladder.
Wait, what?
Nice!
Oh wait, oh no.
I have to delete more pool.
Okay, now we add more foundation.
Foundation is literally causing so much grief for us.
It's the worst ever.
Now they can go swimming!
I think Matara is about to die.
Matara, go for a swim.
There she goes.
Oh, I think I just saw Chucky Cheesy on the counter.
What are you doing in there girl?
She just wanted a little bit of a bath.
Wow, she liked it.
It worked!
The pool worked everybody!
Why is she standing there?
What?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, okay.
This is fine.
Can we change appearance now?
Can we get the special hair colors?
We can!
Look at that.
See?
What is this?
Excuse me?
Is my culture a joke to you?
Oh, everything sucks.
Nothing works.
It's all horrible.
Why is it all so bad?
Guys, I think we are not going to be able to change our appearance.
Not the fake ears.
It's so bad.
Nevermind.
We could give Matara a little pixie cut though.
I wish they gave you sliders for all the hairstyles.
I know!
I don't understand why they don't.
What are they doing?
They are not having a good time.
That's what they are doing.
They are talking about gnomes.
My hair is only for elder.
That's so messed up.
Okay, let's see what Minto wants.
She wants a painting costing at least 500 simoleons.
Her fear is being barked or hissed at by Chucky.
No!
Sculpture.
Earn some money.
Earn a hundred.
We got to get Matara to woohoo.
She also wants a job in music.
And she wants a bar.
This is literally her.
Am I...
Ma'am, did you...
They are talking about ghosts.
They are talking about...
Boob.
Don't throw up.
Don't throw up, Michelle.
Don't throw up on the carpet.
Boob.
Where is... Okay, he is being a good boy.
I kind of love the cat.
Chucky.
Chucky cheesy.
What does this mean, I wonder.
We are going to give love.
We are going to hug the cat.
Stop talking to Matara.
It's disgusting.
What the hell was that?
Everyone who eats is going to throw up and die.
Go take a shower, girl.
You are disgusting.
Where are you going?
Shooed?
Why are you getting shooed?
By who?
What's wrong with the environment?
Wait, what's going on?
Why is everything bad?
Wait, you guys, what am I messing up?
What's happening?
Tell her to go home, please.
Say goodbye to everyone.
What's happening?
Why is she so upset?
Why is the environment so bad?
The smelly food?
Maybe.
You need to decorate.
Oh my god, so cute.
I love him so much.
What are you yelling about?
She just growled at her?
I think it's the stinky food.
She's going to throw it away.
She's taking care of it.
Are you hungry, Matara?
You need to pee a little?
Go pee.
And you are also going to call...
You are going to throw a party.
You are going to throw a house party.
Why did you leave that on the ground?
She is so disgusting.
What did you hear?
Are you okay?
She's probably fine.
Matara said, whoa chat.
Alright,
she's going to throw a house party and she's going to get some guys here.
She's going to be like...
Get the girls together in this game.
Oh my god.
Party with Tiffany!
The guests are invited.
Don't worry about it.
Have a snack of some chips.
And then go to sleep.
It's already 9PM.
Alright Matara, what are you doing?
You are going to...
You are going to make many... No.
Make a single plate of cereal.
You can't ruin that.
I'm not crying in the bathroom.
Everything is fine.
She's going to make many babies.
What else?
Minto is unhappy.
Maybe she wants some more entertainment.
Maybe... I couldn't use this area very much before.
Maybe she wants...
A drum set.
That's fun.
Maybe she wants...
A pinball machine.
That's fun.
She wants... We are going to give her the biggest TV.
Oh wait.
She also wanted paintings.
That's right.
She wanted paintings.
Paintings are expensive.
That one is probably pricey.
I didn't look at it.
Never mind.
It's $55.
$40.
$70.
$75.
$79.
$85.
$88.
There we go.
Perfect.
And... Oh wait.
Was it... It was $500?
Okay.
We will just keep going higher and higher.
Poisonous forest.
In love with a curse.
Sure.
And then let's give her a little couch.
Oh I like the lips.
Now she can watch TV.
Environment up.
Wait.
What do you mean it's party time?
It's literally 9pm.
What are you talking about?
I think they are losing it.
We have like a little bit of fireflies right here.
Hunt bugs.
What are you upset about?
I've done everything for you.
Why are you upset?
Matara Khan, please don't be so picky.
I don't know what Minto is doing.
I think... I think you should go to bed.
Sleep in pajamas.
What?
They say clean!
What's dirty?
There's...aww Chucky Cheese is asleep.
He's so cute.
What is...what is dirty?
What is dirty?
Is this dirty?
Matara, don't eat here.
Oh wait, the water maybe.
Maybe.
Ok yeah.
You take it to your place.
There she goes.
I don't think Tiffany is coming over.
I don't think Tiffany is coming over you guys.
I don't think she is coming over.
Wait, what about the party?
We still have an hour.
And the party is...oh the party score is disaster.
Wait, who woke up?
Chucky woke up?
Is that why the time stopped?
Minto is doing pretty well.
Matara is kind of losing it.
No one seems to be having fun at this party.
Next time take back...
There is nobody here!
What do you mean?
Uh oh.
Chucky!
You bad boy, you!
No, that's bad food!
No, Shillam!
Get out of that thing!
What the hell are you doing?
Why are you up on this thing at 3am?
She is actually psychotic you guys.
She is psychotic!
Get him away from the stinky food.
Now she is crying.
She got fit.
Alright, clean up the food please.
What is happening?
He ate the nasty food and threw up.
This is all your fault Matara.
I like watching him just wander around.
It's pretty good.
She is hungry.
Ok, eat up.
Eat up Matara.
And also Chucky.
Does he not have food?
I guess she has to fill the bowl.
He is starving!
I'm starving the cat!
Why are they so obsessed with the orb?
I don't understand.
Oh, I think it's broken.
Alright, she didn't see that he ate out of it.
So it's probably ok.
Stop talking to her.
Why is she in your house?
Alright, what is this?
Gain a skill point.
Get a bronze robotics talent badge.
That's the turn on baby.
We need to get more people here.
How do we make friends in this game?
How do you make friends in this game?
Yeah, ignore any ounce of... you know... anything.
Advertising?
What is he going after?
Is he ok?
No!
Chucky!
He killed the pet!
He broke my bed!
Chucky Cheese just broke my bed!
Oh my gosh, she is so anal.
I think I need to buy another bed.
What's this one?
Fancy!
Alright, and also clean that up ma'am.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it either.
Oh yeah, let's get her out of her pajamas so we can get her... practice romance?
Wait, I think Matara needs that the most.
Hold on.
There's another Zubat?
There's people here!
Gussy up!
Is that how you get ready?
Gussy up?
Stop doing that please.
Change... wait, how do you... oh wait, wait, wait.
I know how to get it.
I know how to do it.
Wait!
Say hi to this guy!
It's for Matara!
Ok, he just came inside.
Alright, we're good.
Alright, change into everyday.
Matara, you need to go talk to this guy.
Go here, go here.
Alright, we'll talk to him.
Talk?
Wait, flirt?
Wolf whistle.
Yeah, go do that.
Oh, he liked it.
Ok, friendly hug.
Friendly hug.
She's stinky.
It's fine though.
No, no, no.
Friendly hug the man, not the cat.
Cat.
Well, you're going to charm him.
He likes her!
Oh my gosh, he likes her even though she smells bad.
It's fine.
Girl smell, girl smell, boy smell.
Wait, I thought you liked her.
Ok, hold on.
Hang out?
You want to hang out?
Look at them, they're hanging out.
What is this?
She wants to buy a love potion?
See guys, even... Oh my gosh, she didn't even flush.
Matara is so gross.
Even Matara Khan gets rejected for hugs and flirts.
You know?
That's not stink, that's aura.
Yeah, look at them.
Oh, they're hanging out.
They're having a good time.
She's like my big old bug eyes.
I'm bugging out.
She's literally talking to him in her underwear.
I just realized.
She's talking to him in her underwear.
Yeah, she is.
You can bug me anytime.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
I don't know how to get to the...
We're going to make many group... make... not many.
Make... have lunch.
No, not TV dinner.
Make a group meal, mac and cheese.
No, don't make that.
Actually, you know what?
Make that.
Make that instead.
Resume cooking.
What's their relationship at?
A Bruce.
That's his name, Bruce.
For some reason, Chucky does not like the dresser.
He hates it.
Alright.
It worked.
Did not wash hands.
That's fine.
Minto finished making... Oh, toaster pastries.
A delicious plate.
Wait, where are they going?
Is she making another one?
Or...
It's in her inven... There's inventory in this game?
Single pastry.
Eat that.
No, no, don't worry about it.
Just leave it.
It's fine.
Eat the... Eat the pastry.
You're hungry.
She made another one.
And now, she's going to eat that one.
Oh, he's smelling her.
He's taking her in, you guys.
He's taking her in.
He's like, yeah.
Wait, where did Matara go?
Oh, she's just peeing in front of that guy.
And you think she wants a shower?
Or...
Nah, she's going to sleep.
She is tired.
Typical Matara.
Yeah, real Matara behavior.
Is he going to the bathroom?
Right next to her?
Oh my god, he's about to fight her.
She's sleeping with her eyes open.
Greetings to you, my dearie.
I've heard this town has sims looking for...
The perfect mate!
Oh, oh my gosh.
Matara, Matara, Matara, Matara, Matara, Matara.
Hygiene desperation.
You're fine.
Call this lady.
Call...
How do I... service?
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
No, no, no.
This is more important.
It is the...
Which one is it?
Why does the house look like FNAF?
Where?
Obedience trainer?
Call the maid.
We'll get an actual maid up in here.
She's hot!
Call the exterminator.
Yeah, we need that too.
Woohoo!
Wait, how do I find that lady?
We need Matara to... Wait, where did that guy go?
Bruce!
Oh, Bruce, Bruce, Bruce, Bruce.
Appreciate you.
We're gonna appreciate you, Bruce.
We're gonna appreciate you.
What are you up to?
She's doing her own thing.
Oh, it's the lady!
It's the lady!
Greet the lady.
Don't care about the mail.
Unless it's bills.
I think we gotta pay those.
He's trying to escape.
No, sir.
Greet the lady and then pay the bills.
Is this the lady that... Wait, where are you going?
Buy a potion.
Buy a love potion.
Oh my God.
Buy five... Oh, I should have bought ten of them.
Oh my God!
Our next victim.
Ok, we're gonna buy the potions.
We are going to greet him.
We're going to use... Why are they wearing the same exact thing?
I think she has a type.
Oh, I think she's hungry.
Ok, go eat this Pop-Tart.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There she goes.
We'll let her take a shower eventually.
Can she give more?
Hello?
More.
For some reason it's not letting me.
Another guy!
Greet Jason.
Go, Pop-Tart!
Go!
Your needs come later!
Oh, she's showering?
Oh.
He wants to play kicky bag real bad.
He was really into the kicky bag.
Hey!
No!
She wants a car?
Oh my God.
Asana?
She has such high aspirations.
No, she never got to greet the other guy.
She was too busy taking a shower.
Oh, you want to go to sleep?
Ok, go to sleep.
Go sleep.
In your underwear.
It's only 6pm.
I'm going to sell this game.
I hate it so much.
It's so stupid.
Did they all leave?
Nope, he's playing Axe game.
It's funny though.
Please keep it.
Ok, look at her go.
Oh nice!
She wants a table.
Understandable.
I'm going to have her...
Let's go to Matara's side.
That guy didn't even clean up the dish.
This guy sucks.
Serve dinner, mac and cheese.
Come on Minto.
Mata needs to eat.
She'll eat eventually.
Who's this guy?
Lazlo!
He's the Empreg man!
Wait, she's... Greet him!
Greet him!
Nevermind.
The Empreg!
Yes, there was a guy with the Empreg, you guys.
The Empreg guy.
You like that sound?
So they are on a strict mac and cheese diet.
As the cheesy family.
Mac and cheese.
Breakfast, lunch and dinner, baby.
Always some good old mac and cheese.
Nice.
Look at her cooking that.
She's adding those spices.
She's doing a good job.
Sounds unhealthy?
No.
It's probably fine.
And we're going to have a maid soon, so it doesn't matter.
Alright Matara, your energy is up enough.
You gotta go grab a bowl.
Come on.
And then you're going to flirt with that guy again.
Bruce, the guy who's really overstaying his welcome.
You guys, in this world, I guess I'm not a maid.
It's just kind of how it is, I think.
Alright, go appreciate him.
We're going to get your social up with him.
Barely know him.
We're going to make it so that you are...
Give gift.
Ok, here we go.
Ew, this guy stinks.
Get out of my house.
Ok, now we're going to give him this.
Here you go.
Here you go Bruce.
You're supposed to open it and like...
We're going to charm him.
We're going to charm this guy.
See, he likes her!
He likes her!
Ok, now you can go to the bed.
Come here Bruce.
Bruce?
You want a hug?
You want a hug Bruce?
Oh my god.
We're speed running.
We're going to give him a back rub.
Keep running.
Oh my god.
Woohoo in the coffin bed?
Yes!
Matara, you must become pregnant.
It's for this.
What's a suggestion?
What does that mean?
Does she not like him?
Who's calling?
At 10pm?
Answer?
Smelly man.
I thought she liked the boy's smell.
What's she doing?
He pounced?
He's so cute.
Hey Matara.
Yes?
Matara, go have some more food.
She's right behind you!
No way!
Wait, Minto.
What are you doing?
Say goodbye.
Ok, that's fine.
Answer?
Answer the phone.
See you later.
Yeah, go home and shower stinky.
God.
This is working out pretty well guys.
This is working out pretty well I'd say.
No!
I think you should go to the bathroom.
And then go back to sleep.
Oh wait, we lost something.
Wait, what happened?
What just happened?
Oh, they are asleep.
Ok.
This guy is really overstaying his welcome.
He just wanders around the whole house.
Alright.
Ok.
Well, we got a little further with this guy.
What do the things mean I wonder?
He's a friend.
No Minto, stop.
You don't have to do that.
We hired a maid.
There's plenty of environment.
They are fine.
They are so fine.
Everything is cool.
She's cleaning that.
No, you don't have to do that.
That's not your job here.
You're gonna make many group meals of mac and cheese.
Ok.
She's gotta go to both houses to make this happen.
To make this work, you know.
Wow, not Matara actually cleaning and helping.
Oh my god, Minto is gaining all the culinary...
All the culinary experience.
Ok, I think you can eat it now.
Is it in your inventory?
Oh my gosh, we have 5 bowls of mac and cheese!
Wait, we have so much mac and cheese.
When did this happen?
Wait, why do we want to scold Chucky?
Why is she such a freak?
Buy a scratching post.
Oh, that's a great idea.
That's an actual really good idea.
Scratching post.
Oh yeah, and a sculpture.
Let's buy a sculpture.
Where would a sculpture be?
Under here?
Yeah, it's gotta be worth a lot of money.
Lawhenge?
That's so cute.
I like that one.
How about a table?
Yeah, we do need to buy a table.
What's this?
I don't think we have room.
What the hell?
Diver man.
Okay, I like that.
Have they even gone upstairs even once?
Wait, what can I put upstairs?
Here we go.
Alright, where's our maid?
It's 10 AM.
Buy curtains.
We don't need those.
There she goes.
Oh my god, it's huge!
Look how small she is next to it.
Minto is really enjoying making mac and cheese, I think.
There's our maid!
Her name is...
Her name...
...is Aliana.
Aliana!
She's cleaning for us.
Oh my gosh.
She's great at that.
It's like it's her job or something.
Is our diver clipping through the roof?
We can check.
Um...
He might be...
He might be... I actually kind of want to switch it...
No, we never had the roof on.
It's fine.
Gosh.
You think he's got a wedgie?
Wow.
My cat.
Through the roof.
Damn, she's so hot.
I'm gonna... Can I flirt with her?
Influence to bathe.
Where is the maid?
I think Matara's got it.
Hello?
Who is this?
I'm so popular!
Ask a Sim on a date.
Alright guys, that's our goal for today.
The goal is to ask a Sim on a date.
Ok Minto, you are literally obsessed with preparing mac and cheese.
I can't have you live like this anymore.
You haven't even eaten.
I'm so popular.
Oh my gosh.
You have been selected.
Oh, a new magazine.
What?
I thought it was a friend.
We have 8 things of mac and cheese.
Please Minto, you have to eat now.
You've done your job.
Please, serve.
She's serving.
There's 2 things of mac and cheese.
Put the leftovers away.
Eat up, eat up.
The cheesy family.
All set.
Wow, she really got it.
Did she just fart?
No, I think I saw wrong.
I think I did not see that correctly.
We're gonna have Atara get off this.
And we're gonna have her call...
Wait, she can ask him on a date.
Ask Bruce.
What?
His answering machine.
Bruce sucks.
Let's try again.
Call.
Ask on a date.
Bruce.
Community lot or your place.
Let's go to our home.
Oh my god, it's a date.
Hug romantically.
Get off the drums, Matara Khan.
Your date is here.
It's working.
She asked the date.
Oh my gosh, we have so many things.
Tell a joke.
Oh my god.
She's gonna joke.
OK, entertain.
She's gonna entertain him.
What?
She can kiss!
Oh my god.
She's entertaining and telling a joke.
It worked.
It worked, right?
It worked!
It worked.
Oh my gosh, she wants to play...
Tickle.
I don't think he likes whatever she...
She wants to flirt with Bruce.
We're getting all of this.
We're gonna...
Hit on him?
I don't know.
What does that mean?
She wants to dine out with Bruce.
She wants to give a back rub.
Propose.
Stay the night.
They're doing... Oh wait, they stop the kiss.
No, kiss is part of your wants.
What are you...
Can I invite him to the bed?
Come on.
Walk to...
No, no, no.
Jump rope.
What the hell?
How do I get him in bed?
How do you do this more?
Ask.
What turns you on?
Oh my gosh.
Cuddle under the clouds?
What is this?
Influence to flirt with?
What does that mean?
The date is almost a great you guys.
No, don't influence to flirt with Minto.
Nevermind.
Flirt, hold hands.
Do that.
She's gonna give a back rub.
The cat is going crazy right now.
God!
Minto is in the bed!
Minto, go to your own bed girl.
What are you doing?
Go here.
Minto, go sleep here.
Go sleep here.
Don't irritate.
Propose.
Is it to propose to stay the night?
Romantic hug.
Ok, she wants to kiss him.
I'm trying.
Up the arm.
Wait, where is she going?
Wow, she's really flirting good.
Make out!
Ok, ok, ok.
You guys, make out.
Suck face.
You think that will work?
Stop complaining.
What are you so upset about?
Why is she so upset?
Oh, he's gonna give her a back rub now.
Stop.
Suck his face.
Please.
She's about to eat him.
I know I want it to happen.
Oh, what just happened?
Ok, proposed to stay the night.
Wait, did that not count as a kiss?
Oh, he's gotta make out.
That's right.
Dance?
How is that kissing?
Oh, I think he likes her.
Guys, I think he likes her.
Is he staying the night?
Wait, if I relax...
Oh!
Wait, what did I do?
I don't know what I just did.
Give a back rub.
Good job, Chucky.
I don't know.
Oh, I think she's upset about this.
Ok.
She's happy.
Everything is good.
Everything is great.
Everything is perfect.
She's mopping it up.
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, he's peeing.
Ok, nevermind.
Matara, wake up.
Matara.
Wait, unless he sleeps there too.
Maybe relax in the bed.
What is he doing with it?
What is this?
He's got like a little Rubik's Cube that he plays with.
Invite?
I don't know how to do this.
More.
Influence to bathe.
No!
Bruce, please!
Everyone is obsessed with this stupid thing.
Wait, she needs to have a dream date.
Hug Bruce.
She needs to hug him.
Leap into his arms.
Come on, leap into his arms.
Ok, she's happy again.
She's happy again.
Everything is good.
What just happened?
What the hell was that?
She needs to... she really likes back rubs.
She really likes the back rubs guys.
She needs to flirt with Bruce.
What is their relationship bad anyway?
She has a crush on him.
Ok, that's fine.
Caress him.
If I saw that thing IRL I would hop on it.
I think I would too.
We are almost to a dream date.
Wait, what just happened?
Why is he upset?
Charm him.
Wait, what?
Was it bad?
Was the kiss not good?
Smooch him?
What?
Oh no, we only have a minute left you guys!
Hug him.
Not friendly.
Well, it works.
It's almost a dream date!
Kiss, kiss, kiss him!
We got the dream date!
Kiara, thanks for the raid!
I'm trying to get Vitara to have a baby with this guy she just met.
Wait...
Oh she's going to sleep.
No, no, no, no!
No, stop!
No!
I was wondering what that noise was.
Oh, she's watching nothing.
Kiara!
How do you make The Sims?
Woohoo!
I urgently have to eat, sleep, have fun.
Thank you!
Have a good meal!
Hello, KFP.
This is Bruce.
We just met him.
This is Chucky Cheesy, our cat.
This is Minto Cheesy.
No relation to me.
Oh my god, she's eating the bad food.
I think Minto is going to die.
We have Tiffany.
Oh, and then this is Mitara.
If you don't know Mitara-Kan, she's my friend.
I'm trying to make her have the 100 baby pregnant challenge.
And she also sleeps with her eyes open.
Like that.
Never changed Minto.
What did I do?
What am I doing?
You relax in the bed, click the other sim and click ask to join.
You're a great date, baby!
Wait, come back!
Come back!
Come back, Bruce!
Did he leave?
I think he left.
Why
is she upset?
Why is she screaming?
Thank you guys!
Sorry, I'm like so invested in this.
I can't stop like... just everything, you know?
I wanted that to happen so bad!
Progress is progress.
I did say we would try to get Mitara on a date today and we did.
We did get a date.
I just want her to have one baby.
Or get pregnant.
Get pregnant, Mitara-Khan.
In the sims.
What if she called the guy again?
What if she called him, you know?
I'm trying... I'm working on it!
Oh, Mitara's got it.
See?
It's all good.
Everything's fine.
Okay, we're gonna go until morning.
And then in the morning, she's gonna call...
What did she just do?
Did she just eat something out of the trash?
Salvage?
What are you salvaging?
Wait a second.
What did that mean?
What just happened?
Also, Minto has like 7 things of mac and cheese so everybody can have one.
Nobody will go hungry in this household.
She's a dumpster diver.
Minto, you don't need to do that.
This is their house by the way, everybody.
It's in the shape of an M.
Because I'm Mint and she's Mitara.
And this is my side of the house and this is Mitara's side of the house.
And so you can see we have a little thing connecting us here.
There's a window right here.
And then we have our...
Then I have a balcony where I can come up here and look into Mitara's space.
Anytime that I please.
There's a pool.
Yeah, go eat girl.
What are you doing?
What do you mean there's no actions available?
Mitara is ruining it.
Ok, there we go.
Grab a bowl.
Chucky cheesy is so cute.
She has to go all the way around.
Yeah, sometimes it gets a little hard.
There's a front door for each of us but...
Ok, are you going to sleep?
Girl, no, you have to call up.
You have to call your guy, your man.
Ok, we'll let her sleep for a little bit and then we'll have her call Bruce.
Ok.
Ok, we're gonna have you go to the bathroom.
Mint 2024, stop getting pregnant.
Mint 2035, get pregnant.
Mitara caught.
It's Bruce!
Oh my god!
He wants to talk to her.
He wants to talk to Mint.
Wait.
Wait a second.
No, that sounds like... Wait.
Wait.
Wait, what?
Character growth?
No, don't say that.
Wait, it sounds like a... No, wait.
Ok, we're gonna take a shower.
Yeah, she's literally on the phone with this guy.
I didn't know they knew each other like that.
You are simply the coolest Sim I've met in ages.
I'm going to spread the word to everyone I know.
Minto, your reputation is on the way up.
Look, that's what he says.
I'm gonna put you guys on this side for this game.
I hope that's ok.
She just... I don't think...
Wait, what's the issue?
Why is your environment bad?
Ok, Matara, call Sim.
Yes, call him.
Ok, call Bruce.
Even though he is a two-timing little scumbag.
What?
He didn't answer.
No way.
Call Bruce.
Call him again.
Ok, Bruce.
He's not answering.
Oh my god.
Girl, you don't have to do that.
That's not your job.
Call Bruce.
Do you think she's being needy or... no.
He was just on the phone with Minto though.
I cannot believe this.
Ok, hold on.
We're gonna wait like an hour.
Ok.
No, don't chat.
Go call Sim.
Call Bruce.
He's busy, bro.
Maybe if we ask him on a date instead.
Don't toss the cat in the air.
I like how Minto is juggling.
He's...
What if Minto calls him?
Ok, let's try.
Minto.
Call.
Sim.
Ok, he's not answering for anyone.
Maybe he's at work.
Ok, hold on.
Matara doesn't have... I mean neither of them have jobs.
Minto, go find a job.
Isn't that part of what you want to do?
A business.
Wait.
Sell your little robot.
She sold him.
Ok.
Call...
Nevermind.
She's going to sleep.
And so is Matara.
Ok, hold on.
What the?
Why are you guys in the same bed?
When did this happen?
And they're having the same dream.
Oh, I think they don't like the TV.
How do they hear it?
It's in the other room.
Go turn it off, Matara.
And then...
Call... Sim.
Oh my gosh.
This is so scandalous.
I can't believe this is happening.
No way.
He hates her.
Ok, hold on.
We're going to...
Ok.
Chucky Cheesy is sleeping too.
Everybody is asleep.
Everybody is good.
Ok.
It's... Alright.
He should be getting off at like... Let's say 6 at the latest.
Right?
6.
Ok.
Alright.
Now...
Go call your Sim.
Go call him.
Ok.
Alright.
Here we go.
Invite over.
Yes!
Ok.
Wake up!
Minto.
Wake up.
Can my friend come too?
What do you guys think?
It's not a date, but...
We could have her also...
Oh.
I didn't press anything, but it just automatically selected for me.
What if it's a girl?
It won't be.
No way.
Matara-Kan, I swear to god.
What?
How about we have some more?
Mac and cheese.
The best meal of the day.
Is a mac and cheese meal.
Oh, is he here?
Matara, greet your man.
Greet Bruce.
It is a girl!
Oh, nevermind.
I think that's...
Just someone else.
Someone not related.
Move in!
Hell no!
What is a goose?
What is a goose blurt?
Huh?
Be made out with.
Oh, she's making out with him.
Wait.
Be BFFs.
Wait, what's the goose?
Talk to me, goose.
Ah!
Ok, they made out.
So now relax.
Go relax.
Can I invite him?
Invite.
Invite maybe.
Invite to relax.
When she relaxes maybe she will also have him...
Oh, ask Bruce to join.
You guys.
It's happening.
Minto, I think you need to...
Minto.
Go spin.
Hard.
Oh my god.
You guys.
How do I know if she gets pregnant?
Vibrate?
Does she do that?
Wait,
why won't they woohoo?
Keep kissing and woohoo then.
Woo.
She's saying it.
She's saying woohoo.
Ok, she's taking a shower.
Oh, this is horrible.
Make out!
Oh my god, it's proceeding.
It's escalating.
Oh no, I think he loves her.
She doesn't love you!
It's just a... Oh no, I think he's in love with her.
Oh, you're gonna get your little heart broken, mister.
You are just... Bruce, you are just number one.
Wait, what?
I mean...
Usually, don't these guys have like...
They wanna woohoo with so many people.
What's Minto up to?
Oh, hell yeah.
Oh yeah!
Ok, now...
Which, which, which, which...
Are they not the same thing?
Uh-oh, what's happening?
Where is she going?
Oh, she's being shooed away.
No way.
Oh god, the eyeballs.
I can't see... Oh my...
The woohoo.
The woohoo symbol.
Ew, he's whispering to her.
Ew.
Oh.
What's Minto up to?
Give him some love.
This is where we get a peek at Freaky Minky.
No way!
That's not me!
I like how he kinda looks like an otter.
I didn't want to pee!
Can I... Wait.
Ew, why does he growl like that?
Wait, ok.
So let's try for the baby.
Let's try for the baby.
Baby, baby, baby.
Sleep?
No, no, no.
Wake up, wake up.
Ok, now you're gonna relax.
You're gonna relax.
This guy is... Ok.
No, no, no, no, no.
No eating.
Come here, come here, come here, come here.
You're gonna relax.
You're gonna invite...
Wait.
Ask Bruce to join.
No, no, no.
No.
Relax, please.
Ok, then you're gonna try for baby.
No!
Try for baby.
Try...
Relax, relax, relax.
It's chill.
We're chill.
And try for baby.
Ok.
Alright.
Does that mean... Does that mean baby?
Does that mean baby?
Matara's first baby...
Is happening.
And we're gonna end it here, guys.
This was fun.
Thank you guys for the sims.
Matara is successfully pregnant.
And he's leaving.
After all of that.
He said, you know what?
I think I'm good.
And we probably never have to hear from Bruce ever again.
I think.
Bruce is done.
We're over Bruce.
It's time for our next victim.
One baby down, 99 to go.
I have 99 problems and they will all soon be babies.
But yeah, thank you guys.
I hope this was fun.
I got really invested.
In trying to make everything work.
Ew, why Minto?
You were sleeping in their bed.
She's thinking about the woohoo.
Is she thinking about him?
Minto cheesy.
Girl, get some standards.
Have some standards.
Where's the maid?
There she is.
Thank goodness.
She's gonna start cleaning up.
You're okay.
This was fun though.
O2 Minto everybody.
I will see you guys when I see you next.
I gotta finish my salad.
Oh my god, they woohooed literally in front of my salad.
Actually.
Thank you for the super chat.
Such a fun stream.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I hope you guys had fun.
Coping by copulating.
No, don't say that.
Thank you guys.
Maybe next time we'll add some more characters too, right?
So, yeah.
I think I'll make some mac and cheese tonight.
Mac and cheese and get luckies.
Cheesy cheesy family.
Yeah, add Kiara.
If Kiara will let me, I'll add her to the family, yes.
O2 Minto.
Thank you everybody.
Itterasshai, itterasshai, itterasshai.
Bye bye, bye bye.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Bye bye, bye bye.
Oh wait, what did I say?
Sorry.
Thank you for all the super chats.
I have an announcement about a joke, but I will announce it in the next stream.
OK.
I should have my schedule up for the week soon.
Yeah, I have it.
I have it made.
So, yeah.
O2 Minto.
Bye bye.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.